you
galen der stadt secretary of the
norwegian nobel committee thank you for
talking to us about the 2010 Nobel Peace
Prize could we begin by you telling us
who's received this year's prize well
the recipient for this year is Leo
seeable he is a Chinese dissident he had
were he has worked for more than 20
years for human rights in a non-violent
way he was a prominent participant at
the Tiananmen incident in 1989 he is one
of the main authors of charter 08 which
has turned out to be a very significant
document arguing that there should be
human rights in China as there should be
all over the world and he is in a way I
think recognized as the leader of the
Chinese dissident community and he the
Chinese government actually indirectly
gave him this prominent position by the
stiff sentence it meted out in December
2009 when it gave him a term of 11 years
in prison so Lee shabba becomes the
first Chinese citizens get the prize
well that depends on how you define the
Dalai Lama we think the Dalai Lama
although he insists on the cultural
autonomy of Tibet he does recognize the
Chinese framework well it so it but
nevertheless the the price decided to
focus on China this year why has China
become the focus of prize well China has
become an increasingly important power
and hit has made giant strides I mean
china now has the second largest economy
in the world it just surpassed surpassed
Japan and it has made progress in
virtually all fields but not equal
progress in all fields and we recognize
that the human rights situation is not
what it should be
china has signed and even ratified
certain important international
documents and if you look at the chinese
constitution particularly articles 35
and 41 you will see that there are very
strong human rights statements in the
Chinese Constitution itself and and we
think that with this new important
position there follows responsibility we
have to look closely at China's overall
record and then we quickly find out that
despite the tremendous progress that has
been made it falls short in the field of
human rights during announcement there
was a parallel made with the United
States after the Second World War could
you go into more detail about how the
Peace Committee approaches countries
that become great in power I think the
point here and the reference to the
United States was that each and every
superpower and each and every great
power has to be prepared to be
criticized and of course there was a lot
of criticism of the United States
virtually all the time and this goes
with the territory I mean if you are a
superpower people will follow what you
do very closely and that's the way it
should be and now China is a rapidly
rising power and it has to be prepared
for the same kind of review and the same
kind of comments and you mentioned
briefly about charter irate and knee
shall bow in general could you forgive
the more specific detail about what the
charge is about and why shall bear is in
jail well I think the reason is that
despite these international commitments
and despite these clauses in the Chinese
constitution the Chinese authorities are
very afraid of subversion of state
authority and anything that will reduce
the power of the Communist Party
it has become possible in recent years
to have discussion in China about
important subjects but as soon as this
effects the position of the Communist
power and particularly the highest
authorities we see that this is not
possible this will lead to the kind of
reaction we have seen in Liris case so
obviously there is no freedom of
expression despite what the Constitution
says he was found guilty of a subversion
of state power which is a very broad
clause indeed and speaking of state
power one thing that you mentioned this
week was that you were under pressure
from Chinese authorities not to award
the prize to this person is can you tell
us a bit more about that and tell us how
that influenced your decision it did not
have much if any influence on the
committee because there was nothing new
in this we know how the Chinese
government feels about dissidents we
know how they felt about the price to
the Dalai Lama and I have had many
contacts through the years with various
Chinese officials who have explained
this to me it was somewhat unusual that
the Vice foreign minister would do this
but there was nothing new in what she
said and she did not come to Oslo to
talk to me I mean she was here another
business but we did have a breakfast
meeting yeah there are many who
approached the norwegian nobel committee
in support of certain candidates or
against certain candidates they never
get to meet the committee they made meet
me as the secretary and I think it's
perfectly okay to receive these
delegations and in an average year I may
receive eight to ten such delegations so
this is not this kind of pressure or
lobbying or whatever we call it is not
limited to the Chinese
that's not unusual for people to
approach it's not it's not unusual and
therefore the influence is limited if
any so in light of all this and you seem
to be sending out a direct message to
China in a nutshell could you say what
that message is please well in a
nutshell the message is that you are now
becoming a very influential power a
great power and with that power follows
responsibility you should live up to
your responsibilities and you have
certain responsibilities by
international agreements and buy your
own constitutions to implement basic
human rights that's a very strong
message what do you hope the response
will be well we hope that they will take
heed and notice and maybe even do
something in a positive way that's our
hope what the actual response will be
that's up to the Chinese authorities but
it's very important as I explained to
the Vice foreign minister that the
norwegian nobel committee is a totally
independent committee we do not take
advice from anyone certainly not from
the chinese government but not from the
norwegian government either so in this
sense it will be very illogical if the
Chinese authorities decide to punish in
some way Norway because this is not a
decision taken by the Norwegian
government it is a decision taken by the
norwegian nobel committee do you have
any other concerns an award in this
prize yes this is it I mean first of all
it's always difficult to award a Nobel
Peace Prize because there is so much
interest and there are so many
candidates then we had to resolve
whether it would be in the committee's
interest to go into the situation in
China there are obvious complications
here
then we had to decide who with the
dissident be I mean one problem has been
that there are many dissidents and who
should we choose and we know that the
dissident community is very divided so
we had to discuss all these questions
and the result of this these many and
very complex discussions was announced
just now eventually the complexity that
there was a i think a new york times
article earlier this week which
mentioned that there were some distance
who were also saying that the price
shouldn't be awarded to you shall bow
why did you then why did you give the
prize to him and no other dissidents I
think he's more and more recognized as a
leading voice perhaps the leading voice
and i have received much mail from all
over the world and from many different
Chinese dissidents and I've been happy
to see that there is an emerging
consensus in Leo's favor although there
are some dissidents who have explicitly
told us that they would be against a
prize to him all this was to be expected
I know about the situation of Chinese
dissidents and this and communities in
exile and these kinds of divisions they
almost always happen and how many other
peace prizes have been awarded to people
who have been incarcerated I don't know
the exact number but we have done this
many times and this is our human rights
tradition we are very very proud of our
human rights tradition and many who have
written about the Nobel Peace Prize in
books and articles they have said that
this is possibly our best tradition
these are our best prices I'm thinking
of OC at ski 1936 i'm thinking of
software of 1975 are thinking of lake
valenza 1983 dalai lama 89
Aung San su Qi Burma 1991 shirin ebadi
around 2003 so we have a very strong
human rights record we are very proud of
this record and I think the committee
felt that the the question was should we
apply these principles also to China and
the committee said yes because if we
don't apply them to China we do not have
much credibility if we in the future
award human rights prices too much
smaller countries than China they would
say oh it's fine that you do this in in
Iran and in Burma but are you willing to
say this to the Chinese authorities and
the answer came today so is it is a
lineage of history that you wants to
tell the story of human rights and the
struggles and you wanted that's put a
spotlight them spotlight on them and
highlight them to the world and and
say that the Peace Prize has a
particular viewpoint of human rights yes
we are very proud of our a record of
course it's controversial there are many
there's much criticism many negative
reactions but the committee has to be
prepared to stand up for important
principles and human rights is one of
the most important principles you may
ask then what is the connection between
human rights and peace the committee has
long felt that there is such a
connection and of course now in the
international research community there
is a broad consensus among peace
researchers and political scientists
that there is indeed a strong or a
robust connection between human rights
democracy and peace we also feel this is
certainly in accordance with alfred
nobel's will
after Annabelle speaks about fraternity
between nations and if we are to have
true fraternity between nations you must
have human rights and have you been able
to transmit a message through to the new
law at all or his family no we have not
been able to do that obviously he is
under the full control of the Chinese
government and we will not be able to
get in touch with him if the Chinese
government does not incorporate in some
way although in the long run I think it
in these times of globalization I think
it will be very difficult for them to
withhold this information totally and so
what does that mean for the price
ceremony in December do you have to make
alternative arrangements can can someone
receive the prize if they don't turn up
the lecture and receive it we are going
to hold all the events in a way as close
to normal as possible I mean there will
be a ceremony there will be a banquet
there will be a concert and and what we
will do about the laureate that will be
decided when we know who if any will
come but even if nobody comes there will
be a representing the laureate there
there will be a ceremony his voice will
be heard can't understand thanks very
much thank you
you